football arrêtons nous sur la carrière
d'un sénégal est allé à marseille depuis
les années 70 pape diouf a réussi à
bâtir une écurie de footballeur
professionnel
originaires des dom-tom et afrique il
vient d'être nommé directeur de
l'olympique de marseille
reportage dans son bureau de grands noms
du football français et africains ont
défilé pape diouf a été l'agent d'une
trentaine de joueurs et notamment de
l'ama desailly gallas drogba va y aura
robert depuis 88 le sénégalais a réussi
à bâtir une écurie de footballeur
professionnel
le guadeloupéen david sommeil a signé
son premier contrat avec pape en 95 au
téléphone ou presque on ira presque tous
les jours ils ont une relation de père
fils et non dépensés
voilà on discute de tout de la famille
du football de ce qu'il ya à côté du
foot et ça se passe très bien et voilà
on a de très bonnes relations du rail
continue le plus longtemps
c'est à marseille que le longiligne
sénégalais a élu domicile au début des
années 70 en 1975 il intègre la
rédaction du quotidien communiste
la marseillaise pape la bible du
football olympien est le confident
privilégié des joueurs africains et 2009
encouragé par bell et boli il se décide
à arborer le statut d'imprésario si ces
garçons là je suis d'abord venu vers moi
ensuite on menait le cas des airs avec
point c'est que probablement en retour
ils ont eu ce qu'ils attendaient et dès
lors que de tels garçon à la
personnalité aux histoires où chacun si
le même bon il avait donc crédibiliser
le travail que je faisais c'est sûr que
pour ceux qui étaient derrière c'est
peut-être un peu plus facile quoi en
quelque sorte oui je peux dire qu'ils
m'ont peut-être servi de caution morale
aux débats depuis le 1er juin dernier
lorsqu'un journaliste âgé de 52 ans à
entamer une nouvelle carrière celle de
directeur sportif de l'olympique de
marseille
je suis très content pour lui
a marseille c'est vrai peut plus se
reposer parce que
un peu vieux maintenant il faut quand
même que je finisse par mettre en place
en tout cas en règle ne serait ce que
sur le plan juridique tout ce que je
laisse clairement et puis bon ensuite
les garçons par rapport à la tâche santé
mentale que que j'ai avec la plupart
d'entre eux sont libres de m'appeler et
puis de voir ensemble ce que je peux te
conseiller de mieux pour la suite des
locataires certains semblent déjà le
regretté chargé de toute la politique
sportive du club du centre de formation
jusqu'à l'équipe première
pape diouf restera à la disposition de
ses joueurs pour leur prodiguer de sages
conseils amicaux
[Musique]